you know 62% in and you're seeing this
on the screen these are the precincts
that are in this is a slight lead for
mayor Pete Buddha judge over Bernie
Sanders
you see Elizabeth Warren in 3rd and Joe
Biden back at under 16% in fourth Amy
Klobuchar our 13% in these early numbers
now let's just be sure that we
understand this is 62% of the precincts
this is not the whole picture and this
could change as we get more of not only
the raw vote total but also what our
decision desk is going to look at going
in with our voter analysis day and
obviously we want to keep an eye on the
counties and get a feel for which
counties are still out there and where
those counties are and how they might
impact the remaining movement of these
votes as we take a look but I mean
clearly a good night for people who to
judge any way you stretch it I mean even
if he ends up in second place and Bernie
Sanders in first place and that could
happen as the rest these numbers come in
he claimed victory last night he got a
lot of heat for it and it did feel like
you jumped the gun given the situation
as it was unfolding but but clearly he
has performed well here and no doubt and
he's already you know crowing about that
in New Hampshire as he's moved on there
to camp I should point out one thing
Dana the internal Sanders numbers they
put out today say that he's going to
pull this out in the end at about 30%
over Budaj at 24% they are going by
their precinct captains and their
internal vote count we can't you know
confirm that but looking at these
numbers at 62% you realize how lucky Joe
Biden was last night to get out of there
because he's fourth fourth the former
vice president of the United States who
now heads into New Hampshire where
Bernie Sanders is running strong Martha
Brett do you know and do you know what
the voter turnout was and that was one
of the questions last night was if the
turnout was more like 2016 than it was
in 2008 that that didn't sound too good
for the Democrats do we know anything
about that from these numbers they are
still staying leaning with 2016 right
now they're saying that it's roughly
about 170,000 that is not a good number
for Democrats overall it may be Ben
for mayor Pete Buda judge than it is for
Sanders Sanders would have benefited
from the 240 the Barack Obama year
number 240,000 it looks closer to the
2016 170 that holds when we get the full
look at this I think that's one of the
big storylines here as well and it begs
the question is there a candidate who is
really driving this race on the Democrat
side and exciting people to get out and
vote and participate in all of this they
were really expecting blow out numbers
that they might even surpass the number
in 2008 for President Obama which was
around 240,000 so that that's something
to watch really closely and we'll see if
it changes as we get the rest of these
one other thing the Klobuchar campaign
thinks that their internal numbers show
them right neck and neck with Joe Biden
in fourth and maybe even two overtaking
him so again the rest of these precincts
we have to watch closely